what are the different ways you think
AGI might go wrong
that concern you you said that
uh fear a little bit of fear is very
appropriate here he's been very
transparent about being mostly excited
but also scared I think it's weird when
people like think it's like a big dunk
that I say like I'm a little bit afraid
and I think it'd be crazy not to be a
little bit afraid
and I empathize with people who are a
lot afraid
what do you think about that moment of a
system becoming super intelligent do you
think you would know
the current worries that I have are that
they're going to be disinformation
problems or economic shocks or something
else
at a level far beyond anything we're
prepared for
and that doesn't require super
intelligence that doesn't require a
super deep alignment problem in the
machine waking up and trying to deceive
us
and I don't think that gets
enough attention
I mean it's starting to get more I guess
so these systems deployed at scale can
um shift
The Winds of geopolitics and so on how
would we know if like on Twitter we were
mostly having like llms direct the
whatever's flowing through that hive
mind
yeah on Twitter and then perhaps Beyond
and then as on Twitter so everywhere
else eventually
yeah how would we know my statement is
we wouldn't
and that's a real Danger
how do you prevent that danger I think
there's a lot of things you can try
um but at this point it is a certainty
there are soon going to be a lot of
capable open source llms with very few
To None no safety controls on them
and so
you can try with regulatory approaches
you can try with using more powerful AIS
to detect this stuff happening I'd like
us to start trying a lot of things very
soon
how do you under this pressure that
there's going to be a lot of
open source there's going to be a lot of
large language models
under this pressure
how do you continue prioritizing safety
versus uh I mean there's several
pressures so one of them is a market
driven pressure from other companies uh
Google Apple meta and smaller companies
how do you resist the pressure from that
or how do you navigate that pressure you
stick with what you believe and you
stick to your mission you know I'm sure
people will get ahead of us in all sorts
of ways and take shortcuts we're not
going to take
um and we just aren't going to do that
how do you compete them
I think there's going to be many agis in
the world so we don't have to like out
compete everyone
we're going to contribute one
other people are going to contribute
some
I think up I think multiple agis in the
world with some differences in how
they're built and what they do and what
they're focused on I think that's good
um we have a very unusual structure so
we don't have this incentive to capture
unlimited value I worry about the people
who do but you know hopefully it's all
going to work out
but we're a weird organ we're good at
resisting product like we have been a
misunderstood and badly mocked orc for a
long time like when we started
and we like announced the org at the end
of 2015.
and said we're going to work on AGI like
people thought we were batshit insane
yeah you know like I I remember at the
time a uh eminent AI scientist at a
large industrial AI lab was like dming
individual reporters being like you know
these people aren't very good and it's
ridiculous to talk about egi and I can't
believe you're giving them time of day
and it's like that was the level of like
pettiness and Rancor in the field at a
new group of people saying we're going
to try to build AGI
so open Ai and deepmind was a small
collection of folks who are brave enough
to talk
about AGI
um in the face of mockery
we don't get mocked as much now
don't get mocked as much now